The next term I want to define is an event.
You might think of landing on the edge or landing on tails being an event.
We can define an event a bit more broadly that it's a subset of outcomes from the distribution.
So an example of an event would be landing on heads,
and landing on heads as an event is just a set of the outcome .
We could define then valid for a valid coin toss,
and that's the set of outcomes .
The probability of an event is just the sum of the probabilities of all of the outcomes
in that subset.
So the probabililty of an event A is the sum of all the outcomes in A
of the probability of that outcome.
So that should be enough to figure out, what is the probability of a valid toss?
I'll remind you that we defined the probability of heads as 0.49999,
and the probability of tails as 0.49999.
So what's the probability of a valid coin toss?